[Music]  Fennell Americans greetings we all  thought it was funny when Donald Trump  didn't know what brexit was or what the  nuclear triad was or what the  Constitution was we laughed when he  thought he was paying tribute to Latino  heritage by tweeting a picture of  himself eating a taco bowl and naturally  nobody took him seriously when he said  Second Amendment people would have to  keep Hillary Clinton from appointing  Supreme Court justices but look her past  Labor Day and he still hasn't fled for  the Cayman Islands yet and those folks  who support him are still supporting him  and he could still wind up in a place  that looks just like this not if I can  help it I'm Keith Olbermann watch this  space  [Music]